hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we're back to talk about
clovers that happen to be black with the
additions of hearts spades and diamonds
as well because it is time to review arc
10 of black clover and arc which
apparently just just doesn't have a name
for reasons and honestly as a collective
fanbase can we not do any better than
this can't we just give it a name like
asters trial arc heart kingdom
expedition arc whatever it is i don't
care so our bonus mission for today is
that by the end of this video we are
going to need to have found a new name
for this arc because calling it arc 10
is just ridiculous almost as ridiculous
as you not having it press the subscribe
button for the new world review the act
of doing so will immediately alert me to
the fact that you would like to receive
regular black clove content uploaded
straight into your youtube feed but look
i do kind of empathize with the naming
issues of arctin because it really does
appear to act as more of a breaching
period between reincarnation and
whatever comes next week with the
general premise being exploring the
newfound vulnerability of the clover
kingdom as well as diving a bit more
deeply into asta and his devil related
infestation along with glorious curses
as well as the traditional interpreter
style of expanding as many secondary
characters as
is humanly possible to fit in roughly 18
pages of weekly manga it does get to a
point where it is quite impressive we'll
start exactly where we left off with
reincarnation though julius my boy
you're quite small now aren't you i'm
quite happy to hear that he has lost
quote
most of his magic because i'm still not
thrilled that he's alive to begin with
and tabitha is clearly very
very aware of what he's done here
because my feelings on this situation
very much come out through yami when
julius said well i
somehow survived the army immediately
cuts in with no
you were 100 dead please give me back my
resolution which is played for comedy of
course and it's a nice meta
acknowledgement of invoking the really
crappy divisive resurrection so i'll say
no more of it here i know
tabata knows you know you know knows
everyone knows that this was a weak
narrative move but let's try and make
the most of it what i did really like
was how julius decided to deal with
william because once again it showcases
his overall sense of duty because julius
was the one who appointed william as a
captain he assumes full responsibility
for the events that have occurred and
also because he lost to the other
william patrillix thing so julius is
acting as a true leader here which is
great i do like that he never pushes the
blame onto others
even when it may actually be deserved to
do so he does however introduce us quite
rapidly to three pretty monumental
problems one being that there is no
longer an effective wizard king
secondly that the clover kingdom is
likely to be destroyed and finally that
astor is
almost certainly going to die the stakes
of this arc really skyrocketed rather
quickly within its very first chapter
and i guess we'll focus on asta first
like the true
genius he is astor decides that he can
no longer talk his way out of this
problem and ends up being put on trial
for devil related reasons
during which he only continues to
incriminate himself further at every
turn
especially when the charges of
suspecting that he communicates with the
devil or announced to which aster
replies
uh the devil in my grammar is completely
different to that devil which i loved
but this whole process is overseen by a
new character named damnatio kira which
i imagine
probably sounds quite cool in japanese
however in english he sounds a bit like
an edgy teenager's first d d character
you know my name is damnatio killer
macdef
xxx in any case a man whose name is
composed of both the words damnation and
killer well he's mildly imposing
a bit of a dick as well using marie to
last her out
and all of that thing although i do
really like his magic scale magic seems
so incredibly useful and it makes me
wonder well
where the hell were you during the whole
reincarnation thing a man who can
balance the magic of enemies would have
been mighty useful against all of those
extremely op elves
damn it damnatio but word of aster's
trial spreads surprisingly suddenly to
the point where he has his own newspaper
article with this like very flattering
picture actually it makes arsenal look a
lot better than he has ever appeared
elsewhere in black clover sort of like
they've applied to bishon and filter to
the image
in this newspaper astor is quite
literally a handsome devil however this
whole trial business does lead to my
favorite moment of the arc where the
black bulls burst into magical
parliament which is the most harry
potter thing i've heard in the series
yet but initially we have two pages of
close-ups on obscure and mostly
unidentifiable parts of their bodies
however you can tell who each member is
by their dialogue which i love
i think it's great that we've gotten to
the point where we know this squad so
well that they can be identified
by speech alone except for vanessa who
is obviously
tits incarnate so her close up is going
to be her natural cliff face but then we
have what i think is the greatest group
shot of the black balls or even black
clover characters in general to this
point and all around this section just
acted as a mighty big payoff to the
story so far
seeing all of these friends and comrades
that asked her had painstakingly earned
showing up to save him it's a nice
reversal of you know the standard
situation with the ultimate conclusion
being
we're going on a road trip asta and the
black bulls are saved via
a banishment mission which leads us into
the next section of the ark seeking out
knowledge of
curses and there is a lot of cool stuff
here but we do start out with charlotte
who is
she's still quite a joke character all
flustered with yummy and such but at the
very least she does have a pretty
liberating moment where she publicly
admits to loving him which yami takes
quite well in his own adorably idiotic
way although i must say it doesn't
really lead to us learning much in the
end what's more interesting was noah's
conversation with dorothy unsworth where
it is revealed that her mother was
actually killed via a curse and that
older brother extraordinaire nozzle was
forced to hide this information
lest the curse claim him as well and
that makes the whole noel situation a
bit more tragic but it does explain
quite succinctly why nosel was the only
one of the siblings who was not a
complete trash bag and as a result i do
think that going back to read early
black clover would be quite an
interesting experience knowing what i do
now
most importantly though this dreamworld
section grants us our first devil name
which is
mekikula a devil who is thought to be
more powerful than generic devil man
that we just fought off during
reincarnation and hugely important for
events going forward in both the heart
and spade kingdoms we'll get to that but
just to finish off the whole curse
information tangent we also dive into
gordon a bit more and even get to meet
his family which is hilarious
i love that each and every one of them
have the exact same face even the dog
and there was a great subversion at play
when it turns out that his father is a
recovery mage who has used the study of
pain for medicinal purposes so i do like
gordon and his family quite a bit
what's more is that i noticed gordon
confronted his family with the rest of
his g-squad being gauche and grey so
that's a nice little continuation of his
growing bonds with the other blackball
members he might not be as familiar as
he wants to be with the whole squad but
at the very least gauche and gray are
now established gordon friends whether
they like it
or not but now we move on to expanding
into some other nations something i
really enjoyed because i am a big big
big fan of world building
something that most shonen series
honestly really suck at
and black bull it's not the best but i
will take what i can get and what we get
is a very sudden excursion to the heart
kingdom
actually i don't think sudden quite
expresses the feeling well enough
because we basically go from oh mimosa
you've been to the heart kingdom before
right to turning a page and we're all
just immediately within the heart
kingdom like it's no big deal
holy crap that was fast anyway i do like
that the heart kingdom has a distinct
culture of its own at least when it
comes to magic and mana use which
introduces us to another great spirit
actually undine who is kind of like self
but
bigger and water related which i imagine
is meant to be pretty
impressive right like if the salamander
situation was anything to go by the size
of the spirit is pretty much a direct
indication of how much of their power is
able to be utilized
maybe i don't know that's just the
impression i have at the moment either
way there's some you know impressive
crap happening in the hot kingdom most
of which is handled by this really
awkward queen which is also fun
and it's it's kind of cliche but i'm
glad she isn't a standard stoic
power queen as well sort of like the
witch queen although to be fair that
witch queen
oh she's cool still easily one of my
favorite characters in the series we do
have
problems though as per usual one of
which is that our queen of hearts is
cursed by the ever fiendish
and will die within a year that sounds
pretty bad
and as such we are teaming up with the
clover kingdom sort of which i liked the
reasoning behind by the way the whole
idea that for as powerful as these heart
kingdom dude bras are their magical
evolution is just completely
incompatible with the idea of fighting
devils so they need to rely on these
very obscure
brands of clover kingdom magic that have
popped up like yummy's dark magic
oh and before moving on we have a new
magic ranking system as well
something simultaneously less and yet
somehow more vague than the magic knight
ranking system the heart kingdom do
things by levels a system that is also
immediately broken by the idea of level
zero and arcane level that i like stuff
like this regardless i crave structure i
demand it and sadly the magic knight
system gave me very little of that it
was exciting at first before all of the
ranks were rendered
pretty much irrelevant and i think this
system will probably follow along the
same lines just
knowing black clover at this stage but
let's go with it for now especially
since noel is a glorious stage one and
is now casually sporting that valkyrie
armor doing exactly what i wanted her to
do by the way thrusting herself onto the
front lines and no longer having to act
as a mere support mage she is just so
legitimately amazing now like the
magical equivalent of astor but getting
into big news the most intriguing
information comes from the spade kingdom
who appeared to be our new long-term bad
guys now the elves are well they're no
longer a thing in fact we didn't even
know what happened to paltry and the
the three dude brows at this point they
just vanished huh didn't even think
about that until now but the spade guys
are immediately highlighted as quite
serious business because for the first
time in human
history luck does not want to fight
someone a spade kingdom representative
that he spots whilst keeping an eye on
the diamond kingdom pretty scary stuff i
suppose but naturally we do need to
escalate the threat which
is a bit of a difficult thing to do
after having faced off against this
impossibly powerful band of elves as
well as an infinitely powerful devil in
fact power in the series
really has gone i'm going to say
completely off the charts so i am a bit
worried the black clover is reaching
that point in the sharon life cycle
where things just start to get to bleach
levels of ridiculousness and that idea
is probably not helped by the fact that
this arc basically ends with an
off-screen training arc
although i could not have been more glad
to see that six months later pop-up for
a second i was really scared that black
clover was going to be bogged down with
like a legitimate six months of training
which probably would have had some nice
tabata character moments in it but damn
do i not want that so tabitha has made a
reasonable decision to take a mini time
skip here which is exciting because i
imagine that our characters will have
changed quite a bit even though advice
actually i suppose it's a relatively
short amount of time it's not like the
two years that the one piece characters
took or something but i'm sure there is
a lot to learn from the heart kingdom
and i am very much looking forward to
seeing how our characters evolve i'm
also looking forward to seeing finra
basically like
cuck language and you know what language
you're not helping yourself with lines
like
i won't let you get a happy ending that
easily finnroll like
dude just just let your brother get
jerked off what's your problem
and with that i think we have found the
final piece in the name of this arc so
that pretty much does it for this blind
review of the heart kingdom trial spade
threat cuck langrisak and what do you
guys think please leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more black clover content then
please do check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for very maybe regular black clover
goodness delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review
and i'll see you next time